i'm curious when you see the show and
you see the artwork for the show what do
you think of how you look do you just
see yourself i mean how does it feel to
see what that looks like yeah i don't i
don't really see myself which is weird
although however whilst i was filming
as it went on
i like less recognized myself
like this
you know because i was more often than i
was dressed up in my whole like look so
um i sort of stayed in the accent the
entire four months or however long it
was we shot so it was sort of weird sort
of becoming english lily again um
but yeah i don't recognize myself at all
which is very surreal really
quite crazy
did you then have to readjust to
actually being yourself again once it
finished i mean did you have a period of
where you were like okay everybody leave
me alone while i become me again yeah i
do actually find that always hard after
you've played a character like
increasingly and i've recognized that
but it's been more subtle because in my
played characters that you know that i
look like myself or it's not the biggest
stretch so with this it was more
glaringly obvious and i i did have to
sort of actively take myself off and
um
go to the english countryside and just
like go on long walks and then
uh sort of assimilate back
into myself you previously talked about
how you barely met sebastian that he was
pretty much tommy lee and you were
pretty much pamela so
is this the most transformative role
you've done have you ever played another
character that you felt you've taken on
this fully it was definitely the most
challenging role i've ever played and
transformative for sure i literally
could not have ever imagined having the
opportunity to play pamela anderson or
that anyone would have ever thought of
me to do it um yeah sebastian and i
sebastian and i really i think i saw him
twice
for two like afternoons of rehearsal and
then only ever on set at the shoot i
mean we were working such crazy hours
sometimes they'd be like 18-hour days
and so
um
yeah it was it was
yeah it was it which which worked really
well actually because for both of us we
were making such a leap and
and and really
sort of trying to be great custodians of
these characters and and so there was a
lot of effort involved and
so
yeah you bring such a vulnerability and
dimension to your portrayal as well as
moments of real strength
which
make the viewer feel so deeply for her
and the situation that she finds herself
in
where did that come from do you feel
that that developed out of your own
understanding of her and your own
feelings about how all of this affected
her yeah i think obviously i did like
all the research i could possibly do i
worked really hard to feel like i was
as as informed as i possibly could be of
course there is so much i could never
know and will never know
however i you know i read her books
her watched everything she'd ever done
you know her
tv shows her movie her movies um
uh her poetry and and then beyond that
it was yeah how do i relate and to be
honest a lot of it just feels like
relatable as a woman like to feel
um
that there's something really unjust
going on in the in the double standards
between how many women are treated and
to feel the sexism involved in the whole
of the media and the even the legal
system and to feel
um
you know
i as a young actress know what it feels
like to feel like at times you're like
not taking that seriously or you're
patronized and so there was a lot
in it that felt deeply relatable and
deeply human and i think that's why it's
gonna hopefully
people will and when you really find out
what really happened
like that this was a crime against um
a couple that's
newlyweds and their private property was
stolen it's just like
you know like i kind of explored that as
i would any character of trying to they
feel how would i feel if that happened
to me
yeah i mean it's it's so crazy that
there is this crime that was committed
but at the same time the worst part is
that
it's not a crime the way that she was
treated because of it i mean it feels
like that is the bigger crime and it's
not a crime at all yeah legally
sanctioned crime yeah
yeah yeah
there are a number of layers to what you
pulled off in bringing her to life
there's the work that you did studying
her there's the physical transformation
and then the humanity of it all
so were there things that you ever did
to keep yourself in check to make sure
that it never became a caricature
impression
how did you
keep track of that
well
obviously i never wanted to be a
caricature i always wanted to try and
play her authentically i have huge huge
huge respect for her and i really admire
her so i didn't want to there was no
sense that i
i wanted to be a real person you know as
much as like and be as i said as
informed as possibly to learning about
her and
and then i i really had great directors
you know starting off with craig
gillespie who is just he's so cool and
he comes at things with such a strong
angle and such a strong point of view
and he really gives you in like little
clues into how to attack a scene or a
look at a certain moment that's
surprising and that unlocks so much for
you as an actor
so you feel really free and spontaneous
and then we had lake bell and hannah
fidel and our amazing director then
gweneth and we
um i was being led you know i was being
looked after and also our writers tv and
rob who you know
were the other people that i felt like
knew had done as much you had worked as
hard on pamela as i had you know as and
they were there every day so i felt like
there was
a lot of custodians of the role and a
lot of people making sure we were sort
of telling the story we wanted to tell
you signed on to do this threw yourself
into the preparation and then it sounds
like you had a bit of a panic feeling
like you wanted to quit before shooting
so what were you most scared of in that
moment and how did you finally get past
the fear enough to channel it into the
performance you know i i i really do
often feel like i want to
i remember doing a play in the west end
and if someone had said to me just
before the show every single night at 7
15 if they'd gone you can leave out the
back door and you won't you won't lose
your career over i'd have gone i don't
care about the whole audience of people
i'm out so i think that's a general fear
and anxiety that i have which is like
stage fight or a version of
fright but
with this it just felt like such a huge
responsibility and i felt like
i just stopped there was a moment where
i just stopped believing that i could do
it and do her justice and be convincing
and and and and i it really also the
whole transformation with the makeup and
the look and the body and everything
didn't happen to right like
at the
start line you know so it i had to have
a huge faith in the makeup and hair team
and that we were gonna get there and at
one point i was really just scared that
we wouldn't
um
and it's really the biggest challenge
i've ever had as an actor so
um and feeling that responsibility all
just was quite terrifying
similarly did you have a moment where
you really then were in the
character in all of that and you thought
okay i've really got this
well
i i think in the moment in scenes
particularly with sebastian he's such a
great scene partner and there were
moments where i really believed what we
would do like well i really always
believed what we were doing and i i felt
really in it with him and if we found
like our version of this again like of
course we're just basing this on what we
know and we we found our sort of truth
in it and it it felt real and honest and
um
so that was exciting but you can never
really pinpoint who someone is a
pinpoint a character it's always like
growing and moving depending on the day
and what you're reacting to and and
there's such a huge shift in the series
i mean it starts out with this like huge
meeting and falling in love and like
them against the world and then this
like the worst possible thing you could
sort of imagine happening to a newlywed
couple happens in this huge violation of
their privacy and this crime and
everything spirals from then so
it got pretty heavy pretty fast what do
you hope people take from what they
learn about her and this and and from
this
series especially you know because we do
get to learn so much that we didn't know
before what do you hope people know
about her after this
well you know the whole aim of the story
really was to show that the sort of
untold story and to look at what really
really happened which was
as we talked about like a crime that
this private property was stolen it
co-exited
it happened at the same time as the
internet in this first but it's
unbelievable what happened in this this
video you know spread over the world and
and and we'll look we want to look at
that truthfully and look at the
consequences and and explore what that
means as a woman what that meant to
experience that
and um
and and and really honestly to look at
our own culpability as a
as in our own behavior and perpetuating
this kind of
um
culture of
and um of
obsession and privacy being violated and
and negativity and
um
so there's
i think the show is com at times
uncomfortable for the audience if they
if they really engage with them on that
level i think that's what the show is
asking of us you know
um
so yeah
well thank you for talking about it and
really tremendous work in this because
it's just incredible to watch both of
you and thank you so much thanks thanks
a lot
you